I actually met Rob base in my kitchen  he was stripping linoleum and he put  marbling then he left and he made it  takes to know to make a thing go look  what's up man very sour train training  yeah that shit's fight night player I  feel many muscle I think eyeliner I  think I need a little bit more how you  good yeah look at you man  damn you chillin man it almost makes me  uncomfortable  now listen to me I want you to do with  Teddy tells you all right look at me you  got me in your corner man don't worry  about nothin I little I got some sweet  so dis myself  hey sister this a cake find an off-day  beware cake like a superhero  what about rule and rostral [ __ ] I  think Aquaman swim so fast